Lorraine sentai and Lorraine set from
South Carolina I'm stuck I'm hoping that
you can help me get unstuck my career my
living arrangements all need an overhaul
I'm so overwhelmed right now how do I
start Thank You Lorraine hey Lorraine so
I think you know when you feel
overwhelmed you feel stuck I think you
kind of in this moment the rain it's
really probably a cool just to create a
bit of a reflective space and come back
to think of you know what are you what
is your big idea of going to solve and
who is the audience and what is their
pain point and how can you help them
overcome that pain points and a beauty
about this particular when you become
overwhelmed you've got to do list kind
of Islam is cut back to the essence of
your idea your product your service and
why it's going to change the world and
then the other thing you know the magic
of simplification you know what does it
do that you can actually in a consumer
product make the consumers like better
or in a business b2b sort of world I
really try to take off sale or improve
their top line or take capital out of
their organization and let less stress
diving you just got to come back to
basics yeah just focus on where your
audience what idea is going to kind of
really change the world and create a
market for your product or service and
then if you do that you can get really
clear about what's important and
actually one of the other thing this is
I hope I'm not during motherhood and
apple pie here but loads of people get
into you know this is urgent this is
urgent detergent and they're kind of
to-do list grows and grows and it
becomes overwhelming and your head
spinning I'd ask yourself if you've got
a mission what's really important
because everything everything's appear
urgent but it's very few things that are
really important and what's going to
really move the dial and then just focus
here dude I've moved up and actually
Lorraine what you can do mentally is
create a bucket in the corner and if
there's lots of good ideas and they're
not fundamentally important to
write them down chuck it in the bucket
come back to them in 90 days time but
really focus on what's important and it
and you know i'd say where you get
confidence from it's not a real idea and
then the strategy but where you get
successor on is awesome execution really
executing the hell out of that idea i
agree with you i echo a lot of what you
said I think you got to just simplify I
would look at what is the one thing that
if I focus on that that would really
have a big impact and have a ripple
effect because once you start making
progress on one thing and you're getting
some results it leads into everything
else you're doing once you're confident
you're more confident in a business deal
you become more confident your personal
life as well it leads to everything and
so I'd be looking at okay there's a
thousand things that you have to do
what's the one single most important
thing that you fix this it will not only
help that one situation but everything
around it as well and then focus on
doing that and eliminate the
distractions around it